it is seven o'clock this is Sky News
breakfast and these are our top stories
moving towards Kiev new intelligence
suggests the bulk of Russia's ground
forces are just 15 and a half miles from
the Ukrainian capital
as Russian forces get closer to Kiev six
people are injured in a missile strike
on the homes east of the city
well this was the scene as the sun rose
over the capital earlier gunfire and
explosions echoing around the city
Ukraine says Russia is transitioning to
a new stage of Terror as president
zielinski accuses troops of kidnapping
the mayor of the city of militar
Ukraine continues to call for a no-fly
zone and more help from the West
President Biden issues a stark warning
about what that would mean
just understand don't kid yourself no
matter what you all say that's called
World War III
bids for Chelsea Football Club go into
extra time with potential buyers given
an extra three days to get their offers
in after owner Roman Abramovich was
sanctioned
and at the quarter two we'll take
another look through the papers with the
Anthropologist Mariana hotter and the
former editor of the Daily Star Don
Neeson
[Music]
morning all it's now more than two weeks
into Vladimir Putin's invasion of
Ukraine a new intelligence suggests that
the bulk of Russia's ground forces are
now just 15 and a half miles from the
capital Kiev new satellite imagery from
U.S company maxar suggests that Russian
military units are actively firing
artillery towards residential areas as
they move through times near the
Ukrainian Capital all this as President
zielinski says Vladimir Putin is moving
to a new stage of Terror accusing
Russian forces of kidnapping the mayor
of the city melatopo let's take a look
at the latest developments this morning
the ministry of Defense says that
Russian ground forces are now 25
kilometers 15 and a half miles from the
center of the capital as heavy fighting
in the northwest of the city continues
the Ukrainian foreign Ministry has
accused Russian forces of kidnapping the
mayor of melatopol President zielinski
says Putin is transitioning to a new
stage of Terror President zielinski also
claims that efforts to deliver aids to
the besieged city of mariopol were again
thwarted after Russian troops blocked
humanitarian corridors Ukrainian forces
will try again later today to deliver
food and Medicine what the ukrainians
want is a no-fly zone but President
Biden has reaffirmed his intention not
to impose one warning a direct
confrontation between NATO and Russia is
World War III Skies Sally Lockwood has
our first report
for evidence Russian forces are getting
closer to the capital look no further
than these bombed apartments and homes
east of Kiev
six people were injured in the strike
here dozens more have lost simply
everything
newly released images have shown Russian
Advance on Kiev once again in the last
24 hours U.S satellite company maxar say
they captured troops actively firing
artillery towards residential areas
and in what's thought to be the first
kidnap of an official Ukrainian
authorities say the mayor of malitipole
has been abducted by Russian troops this
CCTV shows a man being led Away by force
from the city's registry office
the Invaders captured mayor of the city
a mayor who courageously defends Ukraine
and the people of his community
obviously this is a sign of weakness of
the Invaders they did not find any
support in our land although they
counted on it they have switched to a
new stage of Terror while Russia's
attacks across the country are widening
the Kremlin has a track record of using
chemical weapons and concern is growing
that could be next
foreign
was used against people in Syria the
world watched on in horror but the West
failed to retaliate
Russia repeatedly blamed Terror groups
for the atrocities and the U.N security
Council has voiced concerns Russia is
creating a similar false pretext ahead
of a chemical attack in Ukraine Russia
asked the security Council for today's
meeting for the sole purpose of lying
and spreading disinformation and that is
exactly what you have heard from the
Russian PR this morning the pressure is
now on President Biden to respond but he
has once again ruled out enforcing a
no-fly zone just understand and don't
kid yourself no matter what you all say
that's called World War III okay
the inescapable truth in all this is the
West can't protect the Ukrainian people
from this pain and suffering unwilling
to confront Russia militarily for fear
of a wider war in Europe
it's unclear at what point NATO would
step in but Putin seems hell-bent to
test this to its limits Sally Lockwood
Sky News
uh and as Russian troops Edge ever
closer Kiev has woken up once again to
the soundtrack of War
foreign
Brook over the Ukrainian Capital
gunshots and explosions could be had
fighting is certainly intensified in the
city's suburbs between Ukrainian and
Russian forces in recent days
uh joining us now Sky's Nick Martin is
in Odessa in southern Ukraine Nick good
to see you this morning but I suspect
that you and others close to you will be
will be relatively perturbed by the fact
that it does look like Odessa May well
be one of Russia's next strategic goals
yeah good morning deal uh Odessa is
certainly one of Vladimir Putin's key
Targets this is uh was once seen as the
jewel in the crown of the Soviet Union
and it has been on Vladimir Putin's hit
list since this Invasion began it is a
key port here on the Black Sea just at
the southwest of the nation and we know
that fighting is drawing ever nearer in
fact just a couple of hours drive from
here the other key port city of
mikalayov was struck by shelling last
night it has been under constant
bombardment for the last few days that
is another Port City which would allow
Vladimir Putin to cut off Ukraine from
the sea strategically militarily
economically it would be part of his big
plan that so-called plan to bring around
a new Russia and they're certainly
defending themselves here in Odessa we
were on the streets yesterday talking to
soldiers and civilian as they try to
barricade this precious City in their
eyes on the beach we saw them
sandbagging 350
000 sandbags they've made here to try to
protect shops and houses and also
they've been setting up humanitarian Aid
stations while we were filming in one
yesterday an air raid went off and we
went down to the basement a guy played a
guitar while they were sitting there
until the all clear had sounded and so
they were very worried in this city but
more broadly you know it is a it is a
more worrying picture that slow movement
from the north east down to Kiev from
Russian forces suggesting that they're
on the offensive again and there has
there was an attack in Harkey overnight
five bodies pulled out an apartment we
understand two children a man and a
woman and meanwhile the refugee
situation well I mean those numbers are
just going up and up and up when I came
here just a few days ago we were talking
about a million and a half people
fleeing today we're talking about two
and a half million people fleeing
Ukraine and those numbers are going up
by the day yes it's a Savage War it's a
Savage Invasion but for the people who
live here whose lives have been turned
upside down all they can do is make this
critical decision of whether to leave
and they don't know where they're going
or whether to stay and just try and ride
it out and that is a roll of a dice for
the people of Ukraine as this offensive
draws into a more worrying stage Neil
certainly feels like it Nick for no
thank you
oh let's get the latest now on Russia's
tactics in the conflict particularly the
chances of Vladimir Putin opting to use
chemical weapons joining us now uh
former senior intelligence officer and
NATO planner Philip Ingram Phillip great
to have you on the program this morning
especially so early in the day um can we
start though with with those concerns
that we had you know issued by the White
House echoed by Vlog Vladimir zielinski
and indeed the Prime Minister that the
point that the Russians start talking
about the other sides using chemical
weapons is often the point at which they
use them themselves
it is this is classic Playbook stuff you
know what we're seeing is what
um the Russians have done in grozny in
2008 Saran centers of population when
they can't
um cut them off completely and then
bombard them until they surrender in
Syria it got even more worrying because
they supported Bashar al-assad doing
that and then
um helped him use chemical weapons to
try and break the Deadlocks that they
had around places and with the Russians
then putting out their
um
disinformation
um their mascarovka and then calling a a
meeting in the United Nations yesterday
that gave an extra impetus to it so
that's why UK and U.S intelligence have
said that you know this is a strong
indication of a precursor for a false
flag incident
still do you think the chances of in
using those weapons have been increased
or decreased but by the tactic that has
been deployed before uh by the by the
the the Western allies of of publishing
their intelligence of of preempting what
the Russians were going to do it's
worked pretty successfully up until now
but talking about chemical weapons do
you think that raises or diminishes the
the possibility of their use I think
actually it diminishes it because you're
calling Putin out beforehand but I
single incident to try and suggest that
that's why Russia went into Ukraine
um and and give some form of backward
excuse to the Russian people but
actually to use them in built up areas
and all the rest of it Putin had a
plausibly deniable Outlet when he was in
Syria and that was Bashar al-assad hey
it wasn't me it was him
um he hasn't got that inside Ukraine and
he knows that if he uses chemical
weapons then it takes him personally to
the front of the international criminal
court
um and you know he's aware of that so
he's very good at using information and
using the threat of the big stick in
many cases
um he has got the ability to use it and
that's where we should be concerned we
should be watching it but I I don't
think it's as credible as
um uh some of the commentators are
bringing out which is a good thing
indeed
um Philip you don't need to be a defense
analyst to to know that the Russian
tactics have not well the Russian plan
has not gone entirely according to plan
but I wonder what you make then of of
the way in which the UK Iranians have
been fighting this conflict the tactics
that they have deployed and I mean it
does to my untrained eyes seem to be
particularly effective
it's a master class in defense and it's
a master class of how the resolve of
people your Warfare isn't about Kit you
know we see commentators saying the
nurses have got X number of Tanks the
Ukraine has only got y number for the
Russians are going to win no it's it's
all about people and the resolve of the
Ukrainian Defenders
um enhanced by the sophisticated weapon
systems that have been supplied by the
UK us and and other countries if they're
having a massive effect against the the
Russian military and then the Russian
military being a lot weaker than a lot
of commentators and analysts have
thought you know their Logistics are
absolutely terrible but it's not
people-bit it's the result behind the
people and the Ukrainian Defenders are
defending their Homeland they're
defending their way of life they're
defending their families whereas the
Russians don't have any motivation for
coming in in what we're seeing in the
pictures that are coming out of those
that have been captured so so where then
does this this conflict go next I mean a
couple of weeks ago in fact I was
speaking to someone who knows a few
things about these matters and they
suggested look we're talking Afghanistan
in the 80s you know we're talking yeah
that yeah that that's what the Russians
are going to end up doing is it does
does that look like the direction of
travel it does you know the Russians
militarily have been fixed by the
Ukrainian Defenders they've got very
little uh space to maneuver they don't
have the logistic support to be able to
get them to do things for any sustained
period of time you know the the attack
into the north of Kiev seems to have
sold yet again probably for the for
Logistics and the Russians aren't going
to go anywhere from a strategic
perspective Putin has lost this war full
stop you know there's no way there's no
scenario where he can win even if he
topples the government inside Kiev the
resolve of the Ukrainian people and the
result of the International Community
will continue to destroy Russia so there
doesn't seem to be a path which allows
him to come out Saving Face in any way
shape or form so the the only two real
solutions are some form former Palace
coup in Moscow and we get someone in
who's sensible and then sues for peace
and and helps rebuild Ukraine
um or we're in for a long slog but I
think there's there's very very tiny
green shoots of the ukrainians possibly
getting into a position where they can
start a counter-attack and it'll come to
a point where they might start to be
able to push the Russians out I don't
think they'll ever be able to generate
the military Mass needed to completely
eject them but um they might get under
the forefoot a lot more uh finally
Philippine just kind of on the topic of
perhaps you know the movement of
Vladimir Putin from from post what do
you make of those reports that amongst
others the head of the FSB has been
placed under house arrest that there
have been some significant generals that
have been removed from post it doesn't
scream of a man who's entirely happy
with the way things are going
um he's not happy and you can see that
and it changed his body language the
changes in the way he's dealing with
people
um you're underneath everything there is
a a little man who's absolutely Furious
you know he's a he's a rat that's been
pushed into the corner um he's bleeding
and hurting because he's been attacked
from all sides and he doesn't know where
to turn as soon as he starts to attack
his own Inner Circle which seems to be
happening it's the unconfirmed reports
the moment but that seems to be
happening then there's a greater chance
of inner circle turning against him
that's where we can hope that this will
end quickly if that happens
Philip Ingram great to have you on the
program this morning thanks very much
for being with us my pleasure
with Russian troops repositioning and
moving ever closer to the center of Kiev
fighting and shelling is increasing
across the country
the CGS of Mario Paul and Chinese have
continued with widespread reports of
deteriorating human humanitarian
situations in both also of course those
reports that a psychiatric hospital was
hit by a Russian airstrike in kharkiv
to those have been added fresh targets
the eastern city of donipro along with
the towns of lipsk and Ivano frankiewsk
in the West
Russian troops appear to be refocusing
their Advance on Kiev our special
correspondent Alex Crawford has this
report
Russian tanks and other armored vehicles
in an Eastern suburb of Kiev now
abandoned and damaged but gleefully
driven by The ukrainians Who ambushed
them and pushed the troops into retreat
but this is demonstrable evidence the
Russian military is on the move and
trying several different routes to get
into the capital
the ukrainians are grasping this as an
opportunity to emphasize just how
capable they are of defending their main
city
the Drone footage released by Ukraine's
Armed Forces is now being lauded as a
tremendous military defense in the
footage the Russians come under repeated
attack with soldiers running for cover
Rockets frantically fired in this built
up area it's the main Eastern Highway
leading directly into the center of the
capital
the battle has left military debris
scattered all over the e95 road which
may also help in hindering Russian
progress you can you can still see smoke
in the distance where the Russian tanks
managed to get to they're trying to hold
them back but they're very worried that
they're going to try and make a push
from here or again try down this Main
Road into bravery
but the activity around the capital's
outskirts has definitely picked up over
the past 24 hours
these pictures filmed by journalists
with Ukrainian soldiers appear to show
the troops Under Fire as they engage
their Russian counterparts apparently in
a village in the greater Kiev area
we were invited to see some of the
casualties in bravery a number of them
children
including a 14 year old girl shot whilst
fleeing in a car with her family
the bullets hit her hand and shoulder
she's only a teenager and was with her
four-year-old brother grandmother and
parents we were driving down the main
road from my grandmother's she says and
they just started shooting at us
her father sir guy had part of his hand
blown away he and his family are lucky
to survive he told us the Russian troops
seemed very panicky to me they were
scared he said and they shot everything
that moved
there's increased tension around the
capital and soldiers are wary of
everyone they suspect Russian saboteurs
might be posing as journalists he's
Russian journalist and they're on the
hunt for one in particular
the hospital staff are edgy too and have
found themselves treating some soldiers
but overwhelmingly their patients are
civilian casualties
it's very hard physically and
emotionally he says to see young people
being crippled and dying for no reason
satellite pictures appear to show the
huge Russian military Convoy
repositioning apparently regrouping to
encircle the capital before launching a
prolonged attack on the city center
probably within days
but the man with hero status in Ukraine
for raising Millions to support their
Armed Forces insist they're ready we
will fight from every window we will
fight from every basement we have enough
anti-term results
thanks for our allies from United
Kingdom from the United States so they
will
um
they will lose tanks every street every
block every Crossroads
there are more and more barricades going
up in and around the capital they're
digging trenches and this is in the
middle of the city although we're not
showing the location for security
reasons
either way soldiers and civilians are
preparing for either attack or Siege
they have created a whole network of
these trenches as much as protection but
also from where they can mount fighting
positions
[Applause]
they've been taking on Russian troops
around several points on the edges of
the capital but there's a growing
expectation that the city is headed into
a very Grim few days or weeks
Alex Crawford Sky News here
Sky News understands that bidders for
Chelsea Football Club have been given
extra time see what I did there I had to
submit offers following the British
government's decision to sanction Roman
Abramovich all this following another
turbulent day at Stamford Bridge with
reports that the club had several of its
bank accounts temporarily suspended
Jackie Beltran is here to kind of talk
us through the latest and as we were
discussing last hour there are going to
be no shortage of of interested parties
but the longer that this goes on the
more difficult it becomes for the club
no absolutely because if you just look
at their wage bill for example that's 28
million pounds a month and they can
still receive TV money at the moment but
they can't use that money to pay wages
they can't sell tickets other other than
the tickets they've already sold to
season ticket holders and you know
pre-sold tickets so where do you raise
28 million pounds on a monthly basis
I don't know what kind of Sophie you've
got that not got anything like that
behind my sofa they can't even sell
Match Day programs which they've printed
for tomorrow's match against Newcastle
but they can't employ a seller to sell
them so how do you even get rid of the
programs for tomorrow I mean it's it's
sort of a ludicrous situation when
you've got players as well who are out
of contract at the end of the season
there's a bunch of them including it
says that azpilicueta who you know their
future is now in doubt because how can
they start negotiating for those deals
which aren't done overnight you know
you've got players like Mason Mount who
might have expected a better deal at the
end of the season because he's been a
star for them how do you negotiate that
you can't what about players who've come
through the academy who might have been
given contracts at the end of the season
do those star players that they have
pumped so much money into and trained
since they were kids do those players
then go to another club what happens to
the academy that costs money to run that
was set up by Abramovich to create this
sort of breeding ground of your own
players which it is doing what happens
to that that's expensive I mean there
are so many expenses that how do they
meet them you know they've been given 20
000 pounds as a budget for away matches
but that's not enough for example to get
them to leel next week and back for
their Champions League match although
they say that some of these things have
been paid for up front 500 000 pounds
per match day well actually a normal
match day would cost a million pounds so
they will have to close parts of the
ground because they won't be able to you
know Steward it and have the right sort
of protection there for the fans but you
know all of this is leads to such an
uncertain future in the short term and
at Thomas tuckel who was talking to Sky
Sports yesterday said you know it is
very difficult sometimes to think about
football with all of this going on
to understand the situation is very
difficult to see like where it's going
where it's heading it's maybe impossible
so in the end we we stick to the Mantra
to to live in the moment and and worship
Where We Are
it's not easy but it's out of our
control makes things
um sometimes more difficult but
sometimes also like maybe easier to
accept that we cannot do anything in the
moment and then to wait and constantly
adapt
they need to get it sorted out soon
don't they yeah they do I mean you're
asking the question what does it mean
for the league well we think they're
going to be able to finish the season
and the government view as a cultural
asset so they don't want to see the club
go to the ground you know this is you
know proud proud long-standing you know
part of the community they don't want it
they don't want to punish fans that's
not who they're punishing here but
what's interesting is the fans have been
told stop chanting Roman abramovich's
name he is a hero to fans you know he
brought them five Premier League titles
five fa cups two Champions League so the
reigning world Club Champions so many
titles in in under 20 years
um they have been told to stop chanting
his name
do you think that's going to make a
difference when they play Newcastle
tomorrow
you can take a guess yeah I think it
might make it more likely I think it
probably will make it more likely he
however will nowhere to be seen I mean
he is long gone Jackie Phillip thank you
very much indeed uh stay where you are
still to come on breakfast as Millions
continue to flee the water and Ukraine
the pressure increases on its neighbors
to hopes refugees will have the latest
next
foreign
[Music]
so far more than two and a half million
people have fled Ukraine since the
Russian invasion and exodus which is
contributing to a growing humanitarian
crisis both within Ukraine and in its
neighboring countries one of those
Poland has seen more than a million and
a half refugees arrived in the past two
weeks and the pressure of helping such
numbers is starting to be felt by the
authorities from the Polish capital of
Warsaw as guys Lisa Holland reports so
this is as I said this is this is this
is what we organize temporary
this is just one of the dozens and
dozens of refugee shelters being set up
in Warsaw
a welcome Camp bed after the bunkers and
the bombs and the days of travel
I love you
they long to be home
but family after family tells of the
trauma of escaping War
Julia struggled to reach Kiev train
station with her daughter who has
epilepsy and her son who's autistic
what can I say she says it was so hard
trying to hold my children's hands in
case they fell and carry the luggage
then she reveals eleven-year-old Nikita
is recovering from an operation after
being born with deformed feet she got
here guiding one of her children who's
barely able to walk
others at the shelter need medical help
a young girl is on a drip dehydrated
after the exhaustion of the journey to
Poland now made by a million and a half
people so the problem now because so
many refugees have come to the Polish
Capital because the authorities are so
stretched they're having to provide more
permanent accommodation or boss people
to other Polish cities
this Refugee crisis is defined as an
exodus of women and children across the
city there are makeshift nurseries to
entertain the youngsters
and women distraught they'd left
husbands brothers and fathers behind in
Ukraine
Anna's left her husband in Kiev she also
has to contend with a mother-in-law in
Russia who refuses to accept why she's
fled to Poland
she said oh it's just uh
um little not big not big situation it's
just a little he said mom we had no
house Russian is a destroy our house
across Poland thousands of people who
needed no persuasion of the horrors of
this war are taking in refugees
English teacher Victor Johnson and his
wife offered a home to Marta and her
grandchildren both of the children's
parents are still in Ukraine I didn't
speak to Marta before she came here she
just turned up in the car
and so we met them with high fives and
hugs invited them in made them feel at
home
and that was the most important thing
that they felt safe secure we asked
Roman how he's settling in all things
considered okay
okay nice
just one example of the kindness of
strangers in the midst of Lisa Holland
Sky News Warsaw
well as the war in Ukraine heads into a
third weekend global companies are
continuing to cut their ties with Russia
the latest the cigarette maker British
American Tobacco which said they would
leave the country due to worries about
the safety of their employees uh let's
get more on this Charlotte rumors is in
The Newsroom and covering the story
photos this morning good to see you
Charlotte just how much business do
British American Tobacco do in Russia I
suspect a fair amount they do so it will
be uh below to Russia this news the
owner of those Brands such as rothman's
and Lucky Strike cigarettes has now
decided to pull out of the country and
its reasons for this decision it said ah
because of its ethos and its values and
just two days ago British American
Tobacco did say that well it stopped
short of actually holding its sales but
now it seems to have changed its mind
and done a U-turn and now said its
operations in the country are no longer
sustainable within the current in
environments but it has that it does
hope to secure the future and employment
of its staff around 2000 staff in in
Russia but this is just one of a long
list now of global firms that are
pulling out of Russia British American
Tobacco joining the likes of McDonald's
of Coca-Cola of Unilever in response to
the Ukrainian War now Russia for its
part won't be making it easy they say
they have uh plans that they are hoping
to be able to seize the assets of
Western companies leaving the country
they've also said that they are warning
they could find legally viable ways to
seize International firms
Charlotte thank you
still to come on breakfast we'll be
heading from two women who've been
raising uh raising money to help black
students Escape Ukraine after reports
that some face racism
[Music]
welcome back let's remind you as to our
top stories moving towards Kiev your
intelligence suggests the bulk of
Russia's ground forces are just 25
kilometers from the capital
Ukraine says Russia is transitioning to
a new stage of Terror as president
zielinski accuses troops of kidnapping
the mayor of the city of melaton
and President Biden says an American
intervention and a no-fly zone over
Ukraine would result in World War III
a group of women have raised more than
95 000 pounds to help hundreds of black
students flee Ukraine as Russia's
Invasion continues Karine Skye is one of
those involved and has first-hand
experience having recently left in ipro
herself Karine among others on social
media said that they endured racism
while trying to cross the border and get
their way out of Ukraine well pleased to
say that Kareem joins us now as well as
the Barrister Patricia Daly who's been
helping to raise funds ladies lovely to
have you both on the program this
morning and Patricia I hope you don't
mind if I spend just a little bit of
time speaking to Karine first to kind of
hear her story so cream just tell us
about your time what took you to Ukraine
to danipro in the first place
I was a second year medical student in
Junipero and I was just studying
medicine there's quite a large African
Community in in Ukraine and they usually
go to Ukraine to study medicine or other
stem professions because it's very
affordable
so tell us about the the thoughts that
must have been going through your mind
as Vladimir Putin began to invade the
country and and you started to consider
look do I need to get out of this
country or not when did you make that
decision
you know prior to when the news was
being released in the UK that
um the Russian troops were going to
invade Ukraine the news we're getting in
Ukraine was that it was generally fake
news and nothing was going to happen so
when it actually happened
um that day I woke up and I was on
Twitter and there was an announcement
that kid had been bombed I was I was
shocked and in complete disbelief
because we had the Assurance thinking
from the government in Ukraine that
nothing was going to happen and it was
just you know fear-mongering but to
actually see it happen in real life and
how things just changed by the minute
and progressively got worse it was very
very scary and shocking
to to tell us then Karine about the the
treatment the racism that you
experienced as you were trying to get
out of the country I mean as you say
Ukraine has a has a large black
population I was speaking to one student
from from Nigeria yesterday who was who
was there studying can you describing it
as his second home so so how would you
treat it just give us some of the
specifics if you can
prior to the war breaking out
um I think the student Community we tend
to just stay with other students we
don't really like mix that often
um I think some of the older students
you know who've been in Ukraine longer
some of them go on to marry like
ukrainians but generally the student
population we stay within
um other students so I never really
experienced um racism prior to the war
so when the war broke out and we
actually finally got into the Ukrainian
side of um the border and started
experiencing racism I was completely in
shocking disbelief because I thought in
such a serious situation the last thing
you would expect people to do is to be
racist so this is why um Patricia and
talks and I came together to start
fundraising because we thought you know
fleeing a war is scary enough but the
additional um layer of not having to
face racism and discrimination is just
an acceptable
well let's bring in Patricia at this
point Patricia thank you for being quite
so patient and how did you yourself get
get involved I mean pretty clearly it
strikes me that there are perhaps quite
a lot of people like Korean situations
similar to hers trying to get out of
Ukraine and experiencing the same type
of utterly apparent Behavior as the as
they try to do so
um originally when I started to get
involved it was because I remember that
morning they had bombed um uh Nursery so
it was to assist the children that were
fleeing pain whose lives had been turned
upside down so a quick Twitter search
because you know if you want to keep up
to date sometimes with what's happening
in the world Twitter's the best platform
to do so so when I was on Twitter I saw
that there was lots of black students in
Ukraine
um expressing that they suffering
discrimination when they're trying to
cross the borders and they were not
being allowed to get on trains buses and
so I saw Corinne's tweet and I decided
to reach out to her because she was um
one verified on Twitter so I thought she
would be a credible source to find out
what's happening on ground and what we
can do to support her and to support
those that are fleeing Ukraine so that
they can get to safety as soon as
possible
um so Patricia you you've raised a
significant amount of money just just
explain exactly how that money is used
to help people get out of the country
then
yeah so initially when we first started
um Karim was actually using personal
funds for her from her account to um
distribute to the students that were
fleeing
um and she would send this for
transportation because what we quickly
found when we started to fundraise is
that taxing prices bus prices chain
prices would be in hiked up three times
more than the usual what what the
students would usually pay when they
were attempting to get to the borders
um so when we first started initially
this is what the funds were useful to
give the students transportation to get
to the nearest Borders as soon as
possible regardless of how much the cost
was
um after the students had crossed the
borders we found that there was a need
for them to be accommodated so we would
use the funds to put them in
accommodation as they would only be
allowed to stay at the hostel for
um emergency hospital for just a day so
then we had to Now navigate and find a
way to accommodate them for longer so
they're able to figure out what their
next steps are going to be so generally
it's been for
um
for transportation and accommodation and
now gradually as we're moving forward
and things are settling a little bit for
the students we found that they need
food and some of them have medical needs
such as uh we had one student who had a
family and his son was suffering from
sickle cell and he did not have the
funds to buy the usual medication that
he would need to stop this son from
having a crisis oh dear um just a final
word then from from you Karen um
obviously you've managed to make it I'm
very pleased that you that that you have
I just wonder what your thoughts are of
Ukraine of what you're seeing on your
television is Reading in your papers you
know seeing on your phone every day the
violence
perhaps even the war crimes that are
being perpetrated on on the people of
Ukraine what do you think of that
you know throughout this whole
experience I've just said when it comes
to the politics um in relation to war
that's not really my remit but I just
want us to go back to humanity and
remember that we're all people at the
end of the day and a crisis like this we
really need to band together and show
you know we have each other's back and
really uplift the spirit of community so
we will continue to do our best to
ensure that we can help other people but
I think everybody who's part of the
global Community just remember no matter
what we're all people
karinsky Patricia Daly thank you both so
much for appearing in the show this one
really appreciate your time
as the time just turns quarter to eight
uh still to come on the program we will
be taking another look at the papers
with the Anthropologist Mary Anna hotter
and the former editor of the Daily Star
Donnie's
[Music]
[Music]
time once again to take a look at the
papers today we're joined by the
Anthropologist Mariana hotter and the
former editor of the Daily Star Don
Newsom it is good to see you again and
Don we're starting with you and it's the
front of the Daily Express uh your first
choice uh Ukrainian spice believe that
there is potentially
let's be honest pages are exactly full
of joy and optimism this morning are
they
um this is Putin's plot to Blackmail the
world as you can see there um Russia is
evidently stockpiling corpses of dead
Ukrainian soldiers to plant this
evidence of a forced flag operation at
Chernobyl this is what Ukrainian
officials are claiming
Keys Military Intelligence are saying
that Vladimir Peterson's plan to release
radioactive waste in what would amount
to a terrorist attack basically and then
blame the Ukraine for doing so the
theory is that then the West will be
less sympathetic to the what the
ukrainians are doing on and not send so
much help to them now but you know this
is It's denied on both sides obviously I
mean it's it's counterclaim and claim
and obviously it's an awful lot of
propaganda going on
um you know but where we are and you
know about obviously everyone remembers
from 1986 the horrors of what happened
there
um there is no one allowed in now from
the Ukrainian side supposedly to
maintain
um the nuclear reactors properly the
Russians are supposedly looking after it
but the ukrainians have been held
captive there are saying we have only
enough diesel left to keep the
containment of the uh the nuclear um
reactor safe for 48 hours and you know
what the whole thing with this I mean
I'm of an age one I can remember sort of
like you know growing up with the
nutrients throughout hanging over us and
and being told at school that don't
worry you know if the nuclear Sirens
went off we'd have time to get home to
be with our parents and then to prop a
door up against the wall so you were
saved from nuclear attack and I think
the reason this this war is playing so
so how horrific but horrifically with
all of us in Europe is that the nuclear
threat that hangs over it I mean you
know as Marianne said earlier on I mean
you know this is when we used to go on
holiday this was two and a half flight
away from the UK and the whole nuclear
threat in Europe is what we are
terrified now and and this is what Putin
and the Kremlin are relying on we are so
terrified of this happening that we are
gonna literally let him carry on
invading the Ukraine without doing
anything to us
um
my list is slightly dodgy but you've got
a story in the Ft act you just can't
work out which one it is G7 or jets
oh well we can talk about the G7 so the
G7 have agreed
um to break off uh trade ties with
um Russia so Russia won't be able to you
know I mean not that they in the past
three weeks have been being able to uh
complete business as usual but this
really cements it and it goes hand in
hand with the announcement um from the
EU leaders as well with this Versailles
declaration saying that they're going to
re-arm and also
um work to become uh Sovereign so
independent uh as a block for food
security and Military and so what an
energy as well of course because I think
one of the other things that that this
conflict has really clear in our minds
is how interconnected and how
interdependent we are and how much as
we'd love to turn off the Taps and stop
the ships bringing Uh Russian uh liquid
petroleum gas and oil and you know those
pipelines that crisscross uh you know
the European
um sort of land mass it's incredibly
hard to and you can't do it overnight
and it means that we're still paying
Russia money even though we condemn what
they're doing
so of course there are there are other
levers all the trade sanctions uh being
implemented and they will have a
punishing impact on Russian people of
course the big question is does how much
does Putin care about how much his own
people are suffering or will he say you
know you take it on the chin because I'm
pursuing this imperialistic strategy uh
to expand uh great Mother Russia and I
think the other thing we shouldn't
forget is that there is pro Putin
support it's not there are many people
who are protesting the war in Russia but
you know they're appropriate in rallies
that are being held in
belarusia in Serbia it's not as as
simple as a David and Goliath and that
everybody is condemning Russia of course
China has remained very silent on this
recently yeah they have indeed and Don
one thing that I I think will almost
necessarily follow is is the story in
the front of the telegraph that there
will be a boost to defend spending
whether or not it goes quite as far as
Jeremy Hunter modern secretary is
calling to increase to the to the same
level as the US I'm presuming that's in
percentage of GDP rather than in real
terms
yes it is um obviously and
the UK we spend 2.3 of our GDP which is
the gross domestic product
um on defense a whilst America spends
3.5 and this is an exclusive entry the
telegraph have with Jeremy Hunt as she
points out and former foreign secretary
who is saying that we now given this
situation which let's be honest we could
have seen come in couldn't we I mean
it's not suddenly oh my god really cute
is doing this
um he's now suggesting that we do need
to concentrate on defense spending more
I mean the interesting thing if you look
back at the figures of spending in this
country now I mean sort of like Health
spending is now
149.8 billion pounds and that has been
increasing literally from 1990 up until
now every single year meanwhile defense
has actually gone down every single year
we are now spending 41.2 billion pounds
on defense which which sounds an awful
lot but in the great scheme of things it
absolutely isn't and it's like you know
Trump was very very vocal when he was
president about NATO's
um our defense spending and very
critical of it and Jeremy Hunt is
actually saying that you know okay he
might have been putting it you know
Trump might have been written in a very
obvious way but he had a point and
really we do need now in this country
given how unstable Europe is to actually
maybe consider spending more on defense
it was very interesting uh when the
Ukrainian president was addressing the
House of Commons that standing ovation
everyone applauding you know we're going
to our bit to help you some of the
hypocrisy going on there given the vast
majority of our MPS have actually voted
against increasing um defense spending
we're going to have to leave it there
I'm so sorry we're going to have to
leave it there Marianne do Bring Back
Your Story uh for the next uh of Russia
accusing the US of plotting to use Birds
to spend pathogens Don we'll see you
shortly but after the break we of course
have the very latest as the Russian
forces continue at slow Advance on Kiev
[Music]
[Music]
thank you